We cannot be happier to welcome Senator
Cory Booker as our Class Day speaker.
Please join me in giving him a warm welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
Hello, everybody! I cannot tell
you what it means to me to be invited to
be here with you on this exceptional
weekend, this very long, long weekend that
you all have graduating. I want to say
first of all that I want to give
gratitude to the folks that actually
thought to invite me, some of your
student leadership, but I also on this
day I think it's really appropriate to give thanks
to the entire community that has created
this day and this special weekend for
you. I want to thank the faculty and the
trustees. I want to thank the staff
members. I want to thank all those who
make up the community, especially those
who often don't get thank yous. The
people who manicured the lawns, the
people who clean buildings, the people who
scrub toilets.
[APPLAUSE]
And I want to encourage everyone to
understand on your highest moments in
life, it's so important to let gratitude
be your gravity, to let it keep you
grounded, to understand that whatever the
accomplishment is, you're not here on
your own. I've been to many graduations
but to see the people that you all
brought on the stage and honored,
especially Barbara Baldwin and Tom Sparich,
understanding that these folks
who you see every day are integral parts
of your community, that shows me the
character of this class and already
before I've even really begun my remarks
I just want you to know how special I
think that this community you all have
created is. You can give a smattering of
applause if you want, I'll take a smattering.
Alright, so you guys invited a Jersey
senator to give your remarks. I have a
lot of Jersey pride. I get a really
ticked off when people make fun of New
Jersey. I cannot tell you how many fights
I've had on the Senate floor over Jersey
respect. You know I walk around and talk
to all the other senators and tell them
that their states and their dagnab
mottos really are stealing from our
state.
You know Colorado thinks it's all about
Rocky Mountains, they brag about their
beer. The first brewery was in the United
States of America, the first brewery in the
United States of America was in Hoboken,
New Jersey, dagnabbit. I get ticked off
when I bump into those guys from North
Carolina, Tom Tillis for crying out loud.
They say they're first in flight. Well
I'll have you know that the first
recorded balloon flight excuse me the
first recorded flight in American
history was a balloon flight right here
in New Jersey. I get upset. Even Florida,
the Sunshine State for crying out - oh
listen you Floridians, back off,
because when the sun goes down on the
Sunshine State it is a New Jersey
invention, the light bulb, that keeps the
light on. And even you Virginians, for
crying out loud, what's your motto?
Virginia is for lovers? For crying out
loud, think about our history, people. The
drive-in movie theater was invented in
New Jersey. and there was a whole lot of
lovin' going on there. My mom used to
torture me as a kid, saying I was
conceived in a double feature of Sidney
Poitier, "In the Heat of the Night" and
"Guess Who's Coming to Dinner." I have so
much Jersey pride if you cut me I bleed
Jersey, but I want to tell you I wasn't
born in the state. My mom and dad met in
Washington, D.C., and so today based upon me
not being the only one here that's not
born and bred in New Jersey, this is a
very large class, by the power invested
in me by the people of New Jersey, as one
of the highest-ranking officials in all
of the great Garden State, I want to tell
you, the entire class great Class of 2018,
just like Bruce, Bon Jovi, and blueberries,
just like red tomatoes and Redman, you
are all now officially products of New
Jersey.
[APPLAUSE]
And that means I expect you to defend
our state everywhere you go. Now I want
you to know that I want to impart to you
really one conclusion that may be
different than you already have in your
mind. The conclusion is very simple. I
want to impart to you all that you are
powerful. Now look, this is a day where
you're graduating from Princeton
University - sadly, I have to say as a
Stanford man - the number one ranked
university in all of America, but that's
not your power. I've learned in my life
that power has nothing to do about the
degrees you hold or the title you have.
Power is not measured by position. I want
you to understand that you're powerful
in a way that one of my favorite authors
wrote about when she said, "the most
common way people give up their power is
not realizing they have it in the first
place." These words are from Alice Walker
who wrote powerfully and movingly and
compellingly about what real power is.
I want you all hopefully at the end of
my remarks to think about your power in
a different way and, as you strive to put
more lines on your resume, to realize
that that resume will never ever reflect
the truth of how powerful you are. I want
you to perhaps do like I do, which is to
reject the great man theory of history,
which writes about powerful people in
powerful positions with powerful titles
that moved our nation forward and to
actually remember that this nation was
shaped and formed most by the people
you're never going to read about in
history books, and I want to
[APPLAUSE]
and I want to exhibit this in a simple
story that really has two parts. One part
of the story I've known all my life, and
the other part, the second half of the
story, I learned about in recent years
that just knocked me over. Well the first
half of the story I've told many times.
It's sort of my origin story, which I bet
for a lot of people in your audience
because all of us come from humble
backgrounds, if you go further enough
back in our families trees, there's
difficulties, there's oppression, there's
poverty, and for me, I heard about it all
the time growing up. It was my father and
my mother telling me about their humble
backgrounds. Now my dad had this this way
of exaggerating his childhood. It's like
you know, "Son, I was poor." But now he would
heckle me if he heard me and say, "Don't tell
those people from the Princeton
community I was poor. I was just I was
just po, P-O, I couldn't afford the other
two letters. I was just a, I was just a po
boy from North Carolina." And my father's
crazy. The weather, I never wanted to go
to North Carolina because I thought it
was just always outrageous. And one day he
started a story by telling me, "Son, let
me tell you about the time the tsunami
hit in my town." And I'm like, "Dad you're
from the mountains of North Carolina.
There is no way a tsunami hit your town."
He's like, "Boy, don't you disrespect me.
You know the Bible. Thou shalt honor thy
mother and father. It happened a long
time ago before the internet so you
can't look it up but it happened." Well my
dad was born poor and a humble
background and yet he was able to and
his mama couldn't take care of him. He
was raised by a black family in the town
that took him in. When when he had no
college tradition in my family was folks
in a church that that put dollars in a
collection plate so my father could
afford to enroll himself in a small HBCU
called North Carolina Central. When he
gets down to college and starts fighting
for opportunities he starts seeing lots
of folks showing up, black folks and
white folks Christians and Jews
involving themselves in the civil rights
movement, bashing down doors to
opportunity. He lands in Washington, D.C.,
where he meets my mom and and starts to
find himself because of activism
of others, not just as hard-working grit,
becoming the first African-American
hired by this company and then that
company, and then he becomes IBM's first
black salesman hired in the entire
Northern Virginia-Washington, D.C., area.
[APPLAUSE]
And this gets to the story. My father,
mother suddenly are looking for a place
to live in the New York City
metropolitan area because my dad gets
this promotion, and they start shopping
for homes, and my mom said our guideline
at first was just to find great public
schools, and they ended up looking at
many of the homes were in white
neighborhoods, but when they would show
up in the northern suburbs of New Jersey,
in white communities, the real estate
agents would see them, and then suddenly
tell them, "Oh, I'm so sorry that this
house, it's it's already been sold." Or "Oh
gosh, the the the homeowners decided to
pull it off the market. They're not going to
be sold. They were literally steered away
from white communities, and my parents
were frustrated, so they looked around
and and and and and they found this
small storefront operation with a small
group of folk, black folk and white folk,
Christian folk and Jewish folk, got
together and and decided to try to break
this housing segregation. The year was
1969. I was just a baby, and and my
parents worked with them, and these
incredible lawyers came and decided that
they would would actually set up a sting
operation, and my parents were pretty
psyched. So they would go look at a house.
They would be told the house was sold
or pulled off the market. They would
leave, and right away a white couple
would show up and they would find out
the house was still for sale. Well on the
house that my parents fell in love with,
the house that I would eventually grow
up in, my father and mother showed up.
They were told the house was sold. The
white couple came, found out the house
was still for sale. They put a bid on the
house. The bid was accepted. Papers were
drawn up and on the day of the closing,
instead of the white couple showing up
at the real estate agent's office,
my dad did, and a volunteer lawyer.
Well, they walk into the real
agent's office, and and the lawyer had
probably been preparing his speech all
day. He marches up to the real estate
agent and says, "Sir, you are in violation
of New Jersey fair housing law" and
starts to give him this great, powerful
civil rights speech as my dad sat there
and said "yeah, yeah" and, but then all of a
sudden, the real estate agent stands up
and punches my dad's lawyer in the face, in the face, and sics a dog on my
dad. Now, let me tell you right now, every
time my dad would tell the story, the dog
would get bigger. As I grew up eventually
I'd be walking around the house and my dad
would say, "Boy, don't you dare walk around
this house like you hit a triple. You
were born on third base, young man. Don't
you know all the things I had to do to
get you in this home? I had to fight a
pack of wolves to get you in this house."
And so I grew up in New Jersey, in an
incredible community that was nurturing
and kind, that was good to my family, and
I - it was an incredible privilege - I grew up
with parents who would never let me
forget where I came from, the struggles
that went on, that I owed a debt that I
couldn't pay back, that I had to pay for,
that I was where I was because of this
conspiracy of love. And they told me to
get out into the world. And my father was
impatient. I went to Stanford, to Oxford,
to Yale. My dad's like, "Come on, boy, you got
more degrees than the month of July but
you ain't hot." Life is not about the
degrees you get, it's about the service
that you give, and so I went, while I
was still a Yale law student, moved into Newark,
New Jersey, and I always say I got my B.A.
from Stanford but my Ph.D. on the streets
of Newark, learning from the wisdom and
the kindness of so many people who
embraced me and gave me my first shot,
encouraged me, changed my life direction,
encouraged me to get into politics. To
this day,
the map of the Central Ward of Newark
sits behind me in my Senate office
because those were the folks that pushed
me into politics, believed in me, took a
risk on me. To this day, I still live in
the Central Ward Newark, only senator that
lives in a low-income inner-city
community, because I love my state and I
love her largest city. I wish we had time
for me to tell you all the lessons I
learned in the decade or two that I
fought in Newark politics, joined spirit
and soul with so many incredible people,
but I want to get to the second half of
the story. And it involves just a few
years back, when this great state elected
me to be their United States senator. Now,
I'll tell you this. It was this time
again where gratitude should be your
gravity. When you get elected to be in
this position that's beyond your parents'
even dreams. My mom has this saying, she says
"Behind every successful child is an
astonished parent." And my mom was
astonished. "You're a United States senator, you wouldn't make your bed, wouldn't mow
the lawn." But the challenge of my going
down to Washington for my mom and I was
that six days before I was elected in a
special election, elected in October
sworn in in October, six days before I
was elected, my father died. Now death can
end a life, but it can't end love. And my
father's spirit was with me, but I missed
him, I missed his presence, I missed his
warmth, I missed his hugs, I missed him
teasing me, I missed him making fun of me,
I missed him reminding me to keep my
feet on the ground, not to let my head
get too big.
And so in the wisdom of my mom and some
of my incredible campaign team, they're
like, "Look, before you take your oath,
before you go to the vice president,
Joe Biden, and raise your hand, the last
thing you're gonna do before you become
a United States senator, you're gonna go
to the offices and sit down with
Congressman John Lewis. And and I'll tell
you, my mom and I went to go see
Congressman Lewis, and we walked into his,
office he had prepared a spread of food
for us. And his office looked like a
civil rights museum, except he was in
every picture. And my mom and I were in
awe and the food was laid out and
and and this is John Lewis. When he was
your age he was leaving his university
to go join Martin Luther King. He became
one of the original Freedom Riders. He
at 25 became the head of SNCC, the
Student Nonviolent Coordinating
Committee. He was one of only five
speakers on the March on Washington, the
last one alive. He was considered one of
the bravest men in all of the civil
rights movement because he got beaten time
and time again on Freedom Rides during
sit-ins. On the Edmund Pettus Bridge he
had his skull fractured by the baton of
an Alabama state trooper, knocked
unconscious, bleeding, that bridge red.
This is a hero to me, a giant, and I'm
sitting in his office, and the man is so
humble. He is just so kind. You can see it
in his eyes, and he wouldn't even let my
mom and I get up to go get food. He's
taking some grits and serving us. And
then he's trying to tell me how, how
grateful he is to me, how much it means
to
him that I should be the fourth
popularly elected African-American
senator in the history of our country,
that I am the manifestation of the
dreams that he had, the work that he did.
I was overwhelmed. I now serve with John
Lewis, and I tell you, every time I'm with
him, I'm still overwhelmed. But what is
amazing about him is, he's this teacher
to me in what is power. You see, it's not
about his title. It's not about his
position. It's about the truth that he
lives every day. I see the way he treats
folk. They may be senators or cabinet
secretaries, but I also see how he treats
the folk that served the food,
that clean the hallways. He evidences to me
the truth that you all should always
remember, that someone who is nice to you
but rude to the waiter is not a nice
person. He, he lives this life that - I talked
to him and he doesn't complain. Life is
not about collecting complaints or
gathering grievances. He's always
positive and proactive, and yeah, folk get
in his face sometimes, but another lesson
he's taught me that I share with you is,
hey, you don't have to attend every
argument you're invited to. He lets me
understand what the true definition of
patriotism is. It's not how loud you sing
the national anthem, or the flag pin
you might have on, or or all those
symbols of patriotism.
He teaches that patriotism means love of
country, and you cannot love your country
unless you love your country men and
women.
[APPLAUSE]
You love them all, and he shows me that
you can't lead the people if you don't
love the people. He, he shows me that the
best language you can speak is not
mastery of the English language or
speaking another tongue. Your first
language always must be kindness, and so
this to me is what power is about. But in
that first meeting, we get up to leave,
and now I'm going from one side of the
Capitol building to the other side of
the Capitol building to see the vice
president and become a United States
senator. And somebody should fact-check
me on this but I think the only time in
the history of America has a United
States senator been walking to go get
sworn in and their mother was walking
next to them lecturing them the entire
way. My mom's like, "Boy, don't forget where
you come from. Don't forget the blood,
sweat and tears of your ancestors. Don't
forget that the title does not make the
man, the man or woman must make the title."
So I get sworn in. I look on both sides
of the aisle to find people in
Washington that are examples to me of
what leadership is about, John Lewis and
others I've now found that embody this
ideal that the world has changed as,
Pablo Coelho says, the world has changed
by your example not your opinion. And I
was so excited to be in this Senate and
to mix it up, to become a scrapper for
the state of New Jersey, but one day I
decided to do what many senators do that
have a high self regard for themselves. I
decided to write a book. With a name like
mine, you've got to write a book. And so, I
promise at the corniest joke you'll hear
today. And so I decided I'd go back, but
if you have a father like mine you've
got to go back and fact check everything.
I mean, how big was the dog actually? And
And so I start going back to try to get
the stories of my life and fact check
them. And and and I go back to find the
story of me moving into New Jersey, which
I told so many times. I go search for the
head of the Fair Housing Council from
the 1960s. And guess what she was very
easy to find because she is still head
of the North Jersey Fair Housing Council
today. Her name is Miss Lee Porter and
she is 92 years old, still leading the
Fair Housing movement here in New Jersey.
Now she's not representing black folks,
but she's representing same-sex couples
and Muslim folks who are still being
denied housing because of who they are.
When I brought her to my office ,I'm not
joking, I literally got on my knees
before her and thanked her. How
embarrassing and shameful in fact that I
had never said thank you to the woman
who did so much for me. Every one of us
here in this audience, every one of us
could probably think of people,
especially on a day like this, that
deserves our gratitude. A high school
teacher, a neighbor,
someone to say thank you to.
Well we started talking, and it was
amazing to me. She recounts the story. She
confirms facts and details, but I want to
meet the lawyers who were involved in
all of that struggle. I asked her for the
lawyer that took a punch for my family, a
guy named Marty Friedman. She says I'm so
sorry but he passed away. That hurt, that
I never said thank you to him, but she
says , "Look, the man who organized all of
the lawyers, you can meet him. His name is
Arthur Lessman." And I found Mr. Lessman,
thanks to her, and called him up. And I
said, "Sir, my name is Cory Booker." He's
like, "I know who you are." And I'm like, "All
right, sir. Well you know what you did
for--" "I know what I did." I said, "Okay, sir,
let me hear the story." And he tells me
this incredible story, and, and it's
amazing. He confirms the fact, by the way.
I found out how big the dog was. It was
not a pack of wolves. And, and then my, my
heart is so shocked and moved when I end
the conversation by asking him the
simple question. I mean, this blew me away.
The second half of the story I never
knew. I said to him, "Sir, I need to
understand one thing." He's like, "What?"
"I want to know why, why would you, at that
point in your career, you were just
starting off as a lawyer. You had just
put it out a shingle. You were struggling
to make it. Why would you help black
families try to move into northern New
Jersey?" And the answer he gave me floored me.
He said, "Well I remember the day that
I made the decision." And I go, "The day?
What what day was it? Was it you know
July this or?" No, he goes, "Cory I
remember the day. It was a Monday." And I'm
like, a Monday, okay. And he goes, "I
remember it was a Monday, because the day
before, on that Sunday, I was home sitting
comfortably on my couch watching TV. It was
a Sunday evening movie.
I actually know the name of the movie. It
was 'Judgment at Nuremburg.'"
Now this was back in the days when we
had like three and a half channels on a
TV. You had to get up and change the
remote, change without a remote, change it
with your hands. And he's sitting
comfortably on his couch in Bergen
County, New Jersey, watching TV and then
suddenly something rare happens. They
broke away from the movie to cover the
news. And and what they covered was they
went straight to Alabama because these
marchers had started in Selma, led by a
20-something-year-old young man named
John Lewis. And they had tried to march
to Montgomery in protest of a murder of
an African-American man and voting
rights. And they got trapped and stopped
on this bridge by a line of Alabama
state troopers. And he said he watched in
horror how these folks stood there and
they decided that they would turn around
but first they would pray. And he said
just as they got down to kneel and pray
suddenly the Alabama state troopers shot
gas in on them. He went from watching
"Judgment at Nuremburg" to his own country
as people had teargas raining down on
them and they got raced in by these
Alabama state troopers with billy clubs.
And he watched with horror Miss Boyton
beaten over the head, falling to her face.
Others, John Lewis head cracked open. He
said he watched in horror that this was
happening, his nation. And it was just too
much. He, he couldn't just get up, and got
up in a state of sedentary agitation
where he was so upset about what he was
watching on TV but didn't do anything
about it. So he went to work the next day
on Monday and sat down with the only
other lawyer that was there, which was
his partner Leo. And the two of them sat
there and he said to Leo, "We got to
go to Alabama." And and Leo laughed, not
because it was funny, but because it was
preposterous. They couldn't
afford a plane ticket. They
couldn't even afford to close the doors
to their business one day. They were
struggling to make it and frustrated.
They just sat there for a little while
and then suddenly, in essence, they
thought to themselves and said, why don't
we just do the best we can, with what we
have, where we are? And they got on the
phone and started calling around, and
they found this young woman with a small
organization called the Fair Housing
Council. They were calling around to see
who might need lawyers, and when they
called her, she was like, "Oh thank you
Jesus thank you thank you.
I need lawyers." And they started to get
working. That was 1965. Well, four years
later they get a case file, he gets a
case file handed to him with the two
names on it, Carrie and Carolyn Booker, my
parents. I've been thinking these years
so often about that moment on that couch
when you're comfortable, that moment in
their office. I think about that moment
and how these folks did not allow their
inability to do everything to undermine
their determination to do something.
How they didn't surrender to this idea
that, aw, look at these powerful people
in powerful places, the governor of
Alabama saying segregation now
segregation. Oh they didn't just sit
there and look at the powerful people
saying powerful words and surrender their strength.
How they in that one,
small moment, they understood that to do
nothing is not only to surrender your
power, but to do nothing is actually to
contribute to the very injustices that
you're witnessing. That in so many ways,
the opposite of justice is not injustice.
It is inaction. It is apathy. It is
silence. They understood that it's not
enough to say I am NOT a bigot. It is so
important to say I am an agent of love.
It is so important not just to say I am
NOT hateful. You have to be an agent of
love. It is not enough to say I am not
sexist, I am NOT homophobic, I am not
cruel or mean. It must be an activist
decision that you make and it not need
not be big. One decision in a world where
we are so more intricately interwoven
than we know, one decision by one person
on one day, ripples out into community.
That patriotism of the people on the
bridge, the love of country, which means
you love all your country men and women,
that love on that bridge, one day people
whose names I don't know, standing up
unleashed that force of love into the
world and it instantaneously jumped
1,000 miles and changed the heart of one
man sitting comfortably on a couch in
New Jersey who would then go all
with his patriotism, with his love, with
his activism small acts volunteering on
the weekends. He would go on to change
generations yet unborn. I would not be
here today if it wasn't for that chain
reaction of love built on one action on
one day, one person to another person. It
is a virtuous virus. It's a cascade of
love that we all have the power to do.
Never forget that the biggest thing you
can do on most every day is often just a
small act of kindness, decency, love, and
caring. And so to the great Class of 2018
I say again from where I started, you are
powerful. Power is not on how physically
strong you are. It's on how morally
consistent you are. You are powerful.
Power does not come from your title. It
comes from you telling your truth every
single day in your smallest of actions.
What you decide to do with the dollars
you spend, how you notice the dignity of
the person on the street, how you give
one act of kindness more than you
thought,
2018 you are powerful. And I am telling
you right now, if you show up,
if you show up every day,
no matter what's on the news, no matter
what someone in power said, if you show
up, and you give a little, care a little,
help a little, heal a little, listen a
little, love a little, every single day, if
you don't let the darkness of the world
snuff out your lights, if you don't let
the hatred of another make you cynical,
and turn your back. If you live a life
committed to being powerful, on a daily
basis, to being powerful hour to hour, with
accepting your responsibility, with being
an agent, then you will make your
ancestors proud. Because today I am
telling you, you are your ancestors'
wildest dreams. But for the dream to
truly be real, for the dream and hope of
this country that is in the balance in
this moral moment, it's gonna take an
awful lot of power. So my hope today is
that you leave here and be powerful. Let
this world feel you every day. Walk into
every room, go to every place and embrace
the world with your spirit and with your
truth. And if you do that, if you live
that way, if you strut like you are
powerful, then I promise you the
generations yet unborn will know of your
light and your love. Thank you very much.
Thank you. [APPLAUSE]
Thank you so much, Senator Booker, for
helping to lead the Class of 2018 off on
a high note. Your commitment to serving
ordinary people in the midst of trying
circumstances serves as an example to
all of us as to how to navigate our life
after Princeton with integrity and
purpose. For these reasons, on behalf of
the class, we are proud to induct you
into the great Class of 2018, so we
welcome you.
[APPLAUSE]